[Música]
conocido cariñosamente como belén
francia fue una de las estrellas de cine
más importantes de la nación young
[Música]
en los años 70 y 80 poner el nombre de
jean paul belmondo en una película
garantizaba su éxito en taquilla frente
a la cámara de philippe de broca o llega
a google del mundo se hizo un renombre
en las comedias de acción donde era
conocido por realizar sus propias
escenas peligrosas
[Música]
existe algún entrenamiento para esto
así en esta ocasión trabaje
especialmente los brazos porque tira
mucho sobre todo cuando el helicóptero
gira o libia
jefe o hijo del famoso escultor francés
paul belmondo y de la pintura madeleine
you know jack' de joven se interesaba
más por el deporte que por la escuela a
pesar de su breve carrera como boxeador
del mundo pronto encontró su vocación
como actor su primer gran papel llegó
con sin aliento que le abrió las puertas
para brillar unos años más tarde en otra
película de jean luc godard diego lo fue
pronto se hizo conocido como uno de los
rostros de la nouvelle back actuando
como puente entre el cine independiente
y el comercial las mujeres como tú no sé
mentiroso
en 2001 sufrió un derrame cerebral pero
eso no le hizo perder su característica
sonrisa y ocho años después volvió a la
gran pantalla con un sandwich arba con
un hombre y su perro finalmente tras
boicotear los premios césar durante toda
su carrera del mundo aceptó un homenaje
de la academia en 2017 con dos minutos
de atronadores aplausos para la querida
estrella del cine
[Aplausos]